سواء كنت تفضل المقعد بقربك وانت قاعدين
انا احب
اذا كنت تفضل هذا المقعد اللي بالقرب من
النافذه او على المقاعد اللي على الممرات
يبقى موضوع اختيار المقعد الافضل على
الطائره مهمه محيره جدا هذا المقعد سيجعل
الرحله اما مريحه او بائسه اكيد انا اهم
شيء
الدرجه
الاولى
دفعي ما تزعلش كتير لكن المقعد على كل حال
مشاهدينا الانسب هو باختيار الصف الخامس
تخيلوا والمقعد الملاصق للنافذه هينا
طلعنا صح وهذا على طائرات بوينج 73
هذا ما كشفته مضيفه الطيران الاستراليه
روزي رواد التي قضت خمسه اعوام مع شركه
فيرجن استراليا للطيران هذه خبره وقالت
هذا المقعد الحين راح يصير طقم
الخامس اي واحد الخامس طيب
لميس لديها السر شو هي الاسباب الكامنه
وراء اختيار مضيفه الطيران راح يكون مع
لميس جهينه صباح العربيه لديك الخبر
اليقين انا بالنسبه الي دستنيشن المهم وين
نقعد بالطياره المهم لما نوصل على وجهها
حلوه ومميزه وبنتحمل هالساعات بالطياره
بنقعد مع الشناتي مش مشكله
تفضلي يا لميس شكرا
ما هي الاسباب الكامنه وراء اختياري مضيفه
الطيران الاستراليا
الافضل بالطائره اولها المنظر ممتاز من
النافذه حيث يمكنك رؤيه جزء من جناح
الطائره وهو جزء من المدينه في الخارج
هناك مساحه اضافيه لتمديد القدمين لمزيد
من الراحه خاصه اذا كان الراكب طويلا لا
توجد مسؤوليه مخرج الطوارئ على الراكب في
الصف الخامس
والراكب في هذا الصف يستطيع وتحقيبه صغيره
تحت الكرسي المقابل بسبب المساحه الاضافيه
ويعتبر هذا الصف من اقرب الصفوف في مخرج
الطائره حيث يتم المغادره سريعا دون اي
تاخير ويعتبر من اوائل الصفوف التي يبدا
المضيفون بتقديم الخدمات لهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات